So the phone itself, as we've all seen in the teaser and promo material,...
...is pretty badass-looking.
It's rocking that red coat of paint on the front and the back,...
...with a gold color on the metal side bezels...
...and that Iron Man helmet painted on the back.
This is an awesome combo,...
...obviously a pretty flashy-looking phone from pretty much every angle.
And since the Galaxy S6 has so much reflective glass and metal,...
...it's one of the most eye-catching phones I've ever seen.
You may also notice that limited edition print on the bottom.
Not sure how many of these were actually made,...
...but there are only four digits.
And yeah, this is just not your average-looking smartphone.
And it's not just the hardware that's unique, too.
You also have probably noticed the software is pretty special as well.
The Iron Man Galaxy S6 is rocking an exclusive theme,...
...actually a variant of the Iron Man theme that's already in the Samsung theme store,...
...but with gold accents instead of silver.
So, this theme affects the whole look of the phone,...
...so the wallpaper, the lock screen, the icons,...
...everything you look at on the home screen, all of that stuff.
And it's made its way actually into stuff like the stock apps too,...
...the dialer, it's in the contacts, the messages,...
...and it basically gives them all of this red and gold look,...
...or adds like a red and gold background everywhere.
This is something a collector would buy and like, basically never use.
They put it up in a glass case on display and never touch it.